So!
Keck Weit!
Ja Leute, ich bin auch mal ne Stunde on, mal gucken, was wir so treiben, ne, kein Stream,
sag ich doch, ist ja also mein Stunde Stream ist ja so gut wie nix, ne.
Habt ihr schon den neuen Preis-Champ gesehen, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Ich hab heute Abend noch ein Update gepusht.
Guck mal, guck mal wie nice, wie nice.
Äh, warte, warum nur eine Stunde, weil ich schon ins Bett muss.
Guck mal, ähm, wie nice ich das Ding jetzt hier gebaut habe mit den Notifications,
aber guck mal, man erkennt jetzt auch, dass das eigenes sind.
Ich benutze Manjaro mit E3WM, das Hoffern hab ich übrigens in der neuen Version schon
wieder ausgeschaltet, das ging mir auf den Sack.
Warte mal, also, ähm, kann ich hier draufklicken, das kennt ihr ja schon, nix Neues, ne, ich
hab jetzt hier oben noch so ne, sag doch mal, dieses Icon hier ist doch eigentlich, ist
doch gut, da checkt doch jeder, dass das aufgeht, oder?
Und hier, guck mal, die Notifications gehen jetzt folgendermaßen, gehen jetzt folgendermaßen,
ich klicke jetzt hier drauf, zum Notification einschalten, dann geht, dann geht ein Fenster
auf und dann kann ich auswählen, in 50er-Schritten, wenn Preis unter, keine Ahnung, oder halt
gar kein Limit, wenn Preis unter, keine Ahnung, 1053 und dann klicke ich hier oben auf OK,
jetzt muss ich vielleicht noch ein bisschen klarer machen, dass man dann hier oben auf
OK klicken muss, dann sagt der Benachrichtigung für 360 an Maxpreis 1053, jetzt kann man
das filtern, und, ich gucke jetzt, man kann mal wieder ausmachen, zu zeigen, dass es funktioniert,
gehen wir mal auf die 3090, die wird am öftesten aktualisiert und gleich gibt's Notifications,
wir müssen warten, bis Notification kommt, auf Refresh mal schnell, Refreshen, habt ihr
gesehen da hier, 3090 pro Shop gibt's das für 2049 Euro, excellent, excellent, kann
man wieder ausmachen, guck mal sogar mit Snackbar unten, dass man sieht, was Sache ist, das
passt auch dynamisch an Dark und Light Sieben, zwar nicht schön gemacht, aber es funktioniert,
richtig pock, ne, ja, du meinst, ja, das habe ich auch gedacht, ob ich nicht unten noch
ein Häkchen machen soll, weil das da oben kapiert, keiner, der Preischamp ist noch nicht
ganz fertig, ich habe schon eine neuere Variante, weiß aber nicht, ob ich euch die schon zeigen
will, weil dann würde ich wieder mal IP leaken, und wenn ich IP leake, dann muss ich die IP
wieder ändern später, der rosige Hacker wartet schon, ja, kannst du nicht Beta Beta
Preischamp machen, doch könnte ich, aber der Sinn ist ja, dass ich, ähm, übrigens
da nicht draufklicken, die Uhr ist falsch, ähm, der Sinn ist ja, dass die richtige Seite
unter Preischamp läuft und Beta Preischamp dann für das andere ist, ich habe mir überlegt,
ob ich das nicht, äh, also in einem YouTube Video zeigen ist noch zu früh, weil da kommen
wir 30 Milliarden Leute drauf und dann geht's kaputt, ups, morgen KS, aber vielleicht
mal auf Twitter posten, morgen oder so, dass wir mal ein bisschen Auslastung sehen können,
also ich hab's jetzt übrigens gecheckt, wie viel der Crawler braucht, ich hab den jetzt
in einen Container gepackt und der Crawler braucht, ich hab ihn jetzt einmal mit 16
CPU-Kernen, der braucht 12 CPU-Kerne, knapp 12 CPU-Kerne, dass der Fullspeed durchläuft
und ich hab jetzt ein Proxy drauf, äh, nee, aber was, was, was genau knackt der da, ja
das geht auch, du kannst einfach mehrere Instanzen starten mit unterschiedlichen Shops drin,
das geht, 12 CPU-Kerne braucht der Crawler im Hintergrund und der crawlt jetzt über
10 externe IPs, dass er weniger, weniger gebannt wird, ja, komm mal eine VM an, ich weiß ja
nicht, wozu wir die brauchen, aber vielleicht, vielleicht brauchen wir die, exzellent, ja,
den YouTube Algorithmus, ok, was, was hat er denn erzählt, um den YouTube Algorithmus
zu knacken, ich mein Viewtime ist wichtig, das ist, ja, was, Pols mit YouTube-Stories,
ne, das Video kenn ich nicht, also mit dem Community-Tab kann man den Algorithmus gebanen
oder was, ok, zeig mal, schick mal den Link Leute, dann gucken wir uns das an, so und
solang gucken wir uns, versetzen wir uns in die passende Hacker-Man-Stimmung, wir programmieren
heute aber nichts, kannst du auch mal zeigen, wie man Cloudflare erstellt, einstellen, haben
wir schon gemacht, haben wir schon gemacht, das da, YouTube-Secret-Exploit, ok, exzellent,
jetzt gucken wir uns das jetzt an, das, das muss man sich das angucken, na gut, dass YouTube
broken ist, das ist ja nichts neues, warum verwendet er eigentlich immer so Stock-Fotos
mit noch, ach ne, das ist sein eigenes, sein eigenes Overlay, ich dachte das sind irgendwelche
Stock-Fotos, debated, ich bekomme, weil er immer sagt YouTube-Stories, ich bekomme die
ganze Zeit bei mir auf dem Handy irgendwelche komischen Anime-Memes auf YouTube und ich weiß
gar nicht warum, gestern habe ich auch wieder irgendwas, irgendein Video von irgendeinem
Channel, wo ich schon eine Sache mal geguckt habe und jetzt, jetzt kriege ich irgendwelche
Dinger, die 42.000 Daumen hoch haben und sowas.
Na ja, das echt funktioniert, da gucken wir mal.
Was, wer, where the fuck is Cocomelon, Melon, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok.
Auf geht's.
The YouTube Community Posts and Story
Ey, den Kram verwende ich nie
That's right, it's those little YouTube features that got added in a few years ago
After YouTube decided to create its own legally and copyright free distinct versions
Of the basic features of Snapchat and Twitter
Well, I'm afraid in fact these new features are completely and utterly broken
Now when it comes to content creators who actually abuse the Community Posts
Well guess what, allow me to present to you none other than Dream
That's right, one of the brand new largest channels on YouTube
Das ist doch auch irgendein Minecraft Dude, oder?
He exploded across the entire year of 2020
Ist das nicht der Typ, der in einem Minecraft Speedrun gecheatet hat?
Doch, doch, doch, das ist der Dude
From over the span of just two years, less than 100.000 subscribers to now well over 16 million
How did he do this? Well not only did he make a whole bunch of very algorithmically optimized Minecraft content
He also used the Community Tabs as much as possible
Dream averages around about one to two Community Posts a month
And his Community Posts...
Wie viel, wie viel, wie viel Community Posts?
Dream averages around about one to two Community Posts a month
Eins bis zwei Community Posts im Monat ist doch vollkommen, okay?
And his Community Posts are garnering millions and millions of views each
Dream is then using this algorithmic dominance in the Community Tabs section
To push his videos even harder in recommendations
But just how on earth does it work?
And how can you abuse this feature to become exactly like Dream?
Well, ladies and gentlemen, we've got an algorithm exploit to show off
Now it is going to take a little bit of wordy mathematics
But trust me, they're all very simple
And they are necessary to understand just how broken this exploit is
Ah yes, big brain time kommt jetzt
Now what are YouTube Community Posts?
Well, if you're on PC or you're on mobile and you only follow a few select creators
Then there's a small chance that you've actually never run into one of these bad boys
However, if you're on mobile and you've accidentally clicked on one single K-Pop music video
Then enjoy the fiery monstrosity of spam that is now
DAS STIMMT! DAS STIMMT!
...been sent your way
Community Posts are a feature that YouTube added way back in 2019
And they're honestly a great addition to the platform
It was intended for a new way for creators to send out announcements
Or do Q&As on their channel without creating...
Ist der Preischamp fertig?
Du kannst mal gucken, es gibt ein paar neue Sachen heute
Ich mein, das ist natürlich was, was nie wirklich hundertprozentig fertig ist
Aber mittlerweile funktioniert da ganz gut
...announcement videos which ruin their own channels average video statistics
Now of course any channel with more than one thousand subscribers has access to this feature
And so naturally basically everyone on the internet tried them
And generally speaking, they didn't perform well at all
So the feature is almost completely nuttily abandoned by all content creators on...
Genau! Genau!
Das Ding, das Community Feature hat gesagt
Deswegen hab ich das nie wieder verwendet, nachdem ich irgendwie ein paar mal gepostet hab
...platform
The reason they didn't perform well is because, well, they're a brand new feature
No one knew how to use them, audiences didn't know how to interact with them
And more importantly, because everyone tried to do them at the exact same time
They were massively oversaturated in the algorithm
So everyone abandoned them
Now picture this, you are YouTube
You just made this exciting brand new feature
And none of your creators are using it
Because guess what? It doesn't perform well and it's clunky to use
Are you going to A. Scrap the feature and try again
Or B. Make improvements to it while subtly boosting its promotion on the backend
And so began the death snowball of Chaos
Where every few minor updates to the Community Feature
Saw it gain a minor boost in the algorithm
This of course still didn't make the feature popular with creators
Because everyone had a bad memory of the Community Tab
When they were first introduced and so they never-
Ich mach heute Abend einen Post auf den Community Tab
Dann schreib ich einfach nur rein
Ich hab gehört man muss mehr Community Messages posten
Damit eine Algorithmus boostet
Keck weh
...give them another try
But of course with no one actually using the Community Posts
And YouTube repeatedly boosting it in the backend
Oh no
YouTube had just created the perfect storm
That launches these posts into the stratosphere of the algorithm
My goodness
Now of course before I go any further
I would like to thank my very lovely contacts at YouTube
Ich muss da Abstimmung machen
Okay
...and a non-disclosed K-Pop record label
Wir machen tatsächlich eine sinnvolle Abstimmung
Was für ein Video ich morgen hochladen soll
...just how broken this feature is
So thank you very much
Nee
Das können wir nicht machen
Weil
Dann muss ich mich ja auch dran halten
Dabei
Hab ich erst ein Thema soweit, dass ich das aufnehmen kann
...for your help you majestic tea drinking buggers
...also I do want to disclose that this feature is fantastic
...and alongside the new channel membership features
...that YouTube has been adding
...they've honestly been...
Ja ich übrigens Channel Membership auf YouTube
...muss ich auch noch machen für mehr Stonks
...some great things for content creators
...so thank you very much
...plus they also handle copyright claims better than Twitch
...so it's now also the best place to live stream
I know that is a very natural thing to say
Naja also
Nein nicht wirklich
...one of the five people who live stream on YouTube
...so I guess that makes me the fifth largest live streamer on the platform
Oh god it's so lonely here
Now just how broken is this feature
...well as I mentioned because no one actually uses it
...and it gets preferential treatment in the algorithm
...you've ended up with an accidental gold mine
...where community posts receive more views than videos
...now you would expect a community post to only be shown
...to the community of a channel right
...the people who watch and are majestic enough
...to subscribe to my channel for example
...should be the only people to receive my posts
Ne
Nein
Nein nein nein
Ich krieg irgendwelche komischen Anime Posts
...mit 42k Likes bei mir auf YouTube angezeigt
Das ich
Wie gesagt ich weiß gar nicht warum
...oh that's not how the system works
Oh god that's not how the system works
...these posts are shown to people who have just seen your videos for example
...but then they're also shown to people who watch games or topics that you make videos on
...like for example if I make a Skyrim video then if you watch other Skyrim videos
...you'll probably be shown my community post
...but then something went wrong
...because they're also shown to people who just have never heard of you or anything you do
Oh dear god that is not how the system should work
Oh no now this couldn't possibly be exploited for profit now could it YouTube
No there's no way anyone would do that
No we're all too kind and generous no one would exploit the algorithm YouTube
Ja okay bis jetzt hat er nur erzählt dass es angeblich so ist
...jetzt muss er das ja irgendwie auch noch untermauern
...aber sag mal so ich krieg auch ziemlich viele sinnlose Posts angezeigt
...aber wie bringt ein ein also wenn ein Community-Dings gefeatured wird
...muss ja nicht unbedingt die Videos mehr gefeatured werden
Of course I'm an exploiter
...and I don't just want this post to be viewed by the same amount of people who watch a video
...because I know that these community posts can reach audiences that my videos never can
So how do we guarantee that more people see this community post
Well when it comes to videos actually being pushed in the algorithm
...YouTube uses four general metrics to decide who should see what video
...the title of the video, the description of the video, the tags in the video
...and finally the actual video game or topic that the video is covering
...that way the algorithm can ensure that the right person sees the right video
...and generally speaking the algorithm does a decent job of it
Das stimmt also in der Regel muss ich sagen die Videos die ich interessant finde
...und die ich dann vorgeschlagen krieg die paar also das mittlerweile kriegen die das wirklich ganz gut hin
Community posts don't have titles they also don't have tags and they also don't have designated topics
So how on earth does YouTube decide who to show the community post to
Well it judges this entire metric based off of the key terms that are inside the community post itself
...meaning if I don't know a random British person who has a relatively decent
Also schreibe ich dir jetzt einfach in meinen Community Post rein
...Minecraft, Fortnite, Warzone oder was
...decent audience and drinks a copious amount of tea would happen upon a giant list of the most popular search terms of the last week or two
...and then you would put those search terms in the community post
...and that meant YouTube would just recommend the post to absolutely everyone
Oh no YouTube
...but wait that's not all because guess what YouTube also included a way to double the traction of community posts
...that's right those lovely bots over at Microsoft did a whole bunch of testing in their community post tab
...and discovered if the owner of the account that did the community post i.e. yourself were to leave a comment on your own community post
...then bam that post immediately receives double the traction that it normally would
Why enough is this a feature I have no idea
...now I have exploited this feature before that's right in the past two years ago I used a community poll to gain thousands of subscribers
...by simply having it appear in the recommendations of people to remind them to subscribe to me
...this is when I first started to notice the community posts were completely broken
...as at the time 10% of the people who actually voted in the poll had never heard of my channel before
...now at the time two years ago my channel had only 100,000 subscribers and this post gained 27,000 votes
...70% of these votes came from my subscribers who knew my channel this makes sense
...meaning however that 8,100 votes from this poll were people who really shouldn't have seen the post
...now of course if we take the average engagement rate of YouTube which is the metric determining how many people actually interact with a video or a poll
...and the rate that YouTube discloses is an average of 4% now of course that metric is exceedingly high and the real number is probably much lower than that
...one in 20 people do not interact with a community post
...is an average of 4% now of course that metric is exceedingly high and the real number is probably much lower than that
...one in 20 people do not interact with a community post it is probably closer to one or two percent of people interact with a community post
...but I don't want to sensationalize this existence at all or else we'll be using the higher end of measurements
...so if only 4% of people engage with the post then that means a total of 200,000 people saw this post without ever seeing my content before
...now for a channel with only 100,000 subscribers it's pretty insane to know that 200,000 people who aren't subscribed to you are able to see one of your community posts
...especially when you consider that anyone who interacted with the poll is more likely to get recommended my videos in the future
...and this effect was exactly what happened on my channel the effects of the poll were pretty much instantaneous for my channel
...I gained 8,000 subscribers in one single day and all my future videos had a massively increased viewership
...now this snowball of course continued into the 1.8 million subscribers that you now see here today
...but remember this was two years ago with a tiny channel that had 100,000 subscribers but what would happen now if a channel had 1.8 million subscribers and did that exact same post
...well there was only one way to find out so i did two community posts just to test how broken this feature was
...the first post was just a standard picture post containing a picture of my absolutely gorgeous corgi and some text alongside a metric ton of popular youtube search terms
...fall übelst illusen graf einfach eingeschrieben
...alte 31.000 likes 2 millionen views what the fuck
...period managed to gain 81.000 likes and over 2 million views 2 million views in 24 hours is more than double what any of my videos have ever achieved
...i've only had one video gained 1 million views
...ich hab ein video leute ich hab ein video das hat mehr views
...over a 24 hour period and that is it the fact that a community post is able to beat that is not only unfair it is just insane
...now after five days that post has managed to achieve 124.000 likes
...and if we assume that 4% of the people that viewed the post actually liked it then we can estimate that the post has been viewed 3.2 million times
...that is over 3 times the average amount of views that i get on a video
...so if we were to take a more realistic percentage of between 2 and 3 percent then there's a real chance that that post has actually been seen by 6.5 million people
...this is more than my best video has ever managed and it's on a community post which has just been spammed by a whole bunch of copy pasted lists of
...stopped search terms and then the comment section of that community post is just my audience spamming even more insane search terms
...but if you think this is overpowered well you haven't seen anything yet
...that post was like a refreshing cup of yorkshire tea red label
...this next exploit post is like yorkshire tea gold being pumped directly into your mind
...ladies and gentlemen allow me to present to you the community poll
...ok so before i show off just how broken the community poll is i need to put that in
...just a few ways the basic algorithm on youtube works
...so the moment beyond videos titles descriptions and tags on youtube youtube generally promotes content based off of audience interaction
...if the audience likes the video and comments on the video well those are two interactions and youtube loves interactions
...but what youtube really loves are not 1000 people liking a video and 1000 people commenting on it
...but if the exact same 1000 people both liked and commented on the video that multiple interaction really is what matters
...it's a sign that the video was so impressive that audiences wanted to engage with it as much as possible
...you can even try this out at home by liking this video and commenting on it
...hey see what i did there because it really does prove that you really enjoyed the video
...you have to remember that the vast majority of people don't like a video and don't comment on a video
...heck on average 30% of people don't even watch a video after the 30 second mark
...that is an insane statistic but it's just the world we live in
...now a community poll is a unique video
...content on youtube as it also allows a third way for users to interact
...they can interact on the poll that's right now if we think the same person liking and commenting
...has two times the impact on the algorithm then think that someone voting liking and commenting
...has having three times the impact because if anything it has more than three times the impact
...it's like it cubes the impact it is absolutely insane just how broken it is
...dass man das so nach dem motto damit es richtig wirkt müsst ihr dann liken,comment und,und,und
...was muss man machen,favoriten?
...ne was?
...excellent,das probier schnarchen aus
Ich glaube, ich glaub's dir immer noch nicht, dass das...
Ey, jetzt braucht man noch, jetzt braucht man nur noch eine Abstimmungsvariante, die, ähm, multiple Abstimmungen machen kann.
Dann, dann ist das 50 Billionen Interactions.
Alter, 148.000.
Na gut, der tupat 1,3 Millionen.
Haha, ja, ja.
I'm not subscribed, ja.
Na gut, da haben auch viele Troll votet, aber trotzdem.
Ah, exellent.
Alter, da haben 300, guck, da ist das Mann, 361.000 abgestimmt. What the fuck?
Okay, ich mach nachher Community-Post, Leute.
Kann man, kann man, kann man Bilder posten? Ja, klar kann man Bilder posten. Im YouTube-Community-Tab.
Wobei, wir können, wir können das einfach on stream schreiben, erst mal gucken, gucken, ob ich mich einloggen kann auf der anderen Seite.
YouTube, gucken wir, gucken wir, ob ich mich eingeloggt krieg, was ich da wieder für ne Scheiße empfohlen krieg, ist nicht normal.
Jawoll, mein Kanal.
Community-Tab.
Das habt ihr, verwendet ihr den Kram, die Abstimmung-Bild, okay, in das Bild muss auf jeden Fall nicht der Preis-Champ, da muss Pepo-Fat-Gif sein.
Das Pepo-Fat-Gif muss da rein.
Gif.
Oder wie die coolen Leute sagen, die aber unrecht haben, Gif.
What the fuck, was seh ich hier? Das muss da rein.
Ich muss noch einen Poll machen, ja, da fällt mir schon irgendwas blödes ein, habt ihr gute Ideen für ne Umfrage auf YouTube, irgendwas total bescheuertes.
Wir machen einfach ne Umfrage, ob, genau, ich mach einen für die Umfrage, heißt das Gif oder Jif?
Gif oder Jif? Und dann mach ich ein Bild drüber.
Aber man muss ja schon sagen, also, das bringt dir nur Exposure, also, mal angenommen, du machst das und deine Videos sind halt einfach kacke, dann klappt das auch nicht.
So geil, wenn du das überlegst.
Oh, Big Brain Quickmuffs kommt jetzt, Quickmuffs.
Ja, naja, es gibt nicht so viele große Channels, deren Videos kacke sind. Es gibt vielleicht große Channels, den Videos, die dir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Ja, also, Dings hier, wie heißen die, Logan Paul, Jake, was auch immer, es gibt ganz viele Schwachsins-Videos, die ich mir nicht angucken würde, aber die sind nicht schlecht, also nicht schlecht für YouTube.
Boah, boah, zwölf Millionen.
Ja gut, aber so ein Ding kann man auch einfacher anzeigen als ein Video, das kannst du in irgendeinem Feed einstellen.
Was? Das ist aber heftig, ey.
Heftig, hat er Link zu diesem Post drin?
Also, ich werde das jetzt nicht exploiten, aber ich mache heute Abend mal so einen sinnlosen Post dazu.
Na gut, bei ihm ist es jetzt auch so, dass die Leute es da richtig drauf anspringen.
Das stimmt wohl.
Ah, man kann kein Bild und Paul hinzufügen, so wie es aussieht.
Boah, bam, null.
Kein Quatsch, sehr geil.
Interessante Sache.
Okay Leute, nachdem ich kein Bild posten kann, muss ich irgendeine andere sinnlose Abstimmung machen.
Null wie Kekwinde.
Bester Lieblings YouTuber, boah, puh.
Keine Ahnung.
Interessant, interessant.
Was sind YouTube Shorts? Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Oh, äh, nicht YouTube, ich kann nicht schreiben.
Ist das TikTok für YouTube oder was?
Das haben wir noch gebraucht, Alter.
Und warum müssen die vertikal sein?
Ich kriege immer Anfälle, wenn die Leute ihre Videos in vertikal machen.
Jetzt kopiert ihr den TikTok, ja.
Okay Leute, ich brauche noch eine richtige Big Brain Umfrage für YouTube.
Wo Interacted wird, wo richtig krass Interacted wird.
Irgendwas, irgendwas richtig dummes.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, was richtig dummes, wo jeder draufklickt.
AMD Intel, das ist gut, da springen die Leute schon mal drauf an.
Wir machen lieber AMD Rechner mit AMD Graphikkarte oder Intel Rechner mit Nvidia Graphikkarte.
PC versus Konsole, PC versus Konsole ist auch nicht schlecht.
PC beste Scheiß-Shitbox. Wobei, wenn man Shit reinschreibt, wird das bestimmt gebannt von den Umfragen.
Das muss ja family-friendly sein, alles.
Das muss ja alles family-friendly sein.
Das ist interessant. Was ist was?
Excellent.
Nein, nein, nein, Corona, ich mache nichts politischer Umfragen da irgendwie rein.
Da flippen die Leute wieder aus.
Was, echt?
Das ist ja geil.
Ja, das war ich ja auch.
Lustig.
Ich habe auf meiner Frontpage überhaupt keine Community Post. Guckt euch das an?
Null, oder? Ach doch, hier.
Extra 3.
Ja.
Stimmt, war ich aus dem neuen Left 4 Dead geworden.
Wer macht das Video?
Das ist ein Spiel, was mich tatsächlich ein bisschen interessiert hat.
Mach die Ansicht kleiner, dann hast du mehr. Wirklich?
Gibt es echt Leute, die auf dieser Größe YouTube gucken? Kann ich mir gerade vorstellen.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Wie wollt ihr sagen, ich bin der einzige, der auf ultra fett guckt?
Es gibt bestimmt auch so ein paar richtig abgedrehte Leute, die gucken das so oder irgendwie so.
So hier, Leute, bestimmt haben die YouTuber 75%, dass du mehr Crap siehst.
Dann super weit 4K, 75% High DPI, 5 Milliarden Euro Monitor.
Okay, ich brauche immer noch eine gute Umfrage.
Ist PC beste? Nein.
1000 Herz natürlich.
Ja, Leute, also wie gesagt, ich habe heute nichts vor, ich bin auch in 20 Minuten wieder auf.
Warum ist die 3060 nicht drin? Was ist da los? War die heute schon mal da?
Ja, die war heute schon mal da für 499.
Es ist ja auch ganz toll, normalerweise ist UVP 499, man kann es jetzt für den Schnapper von 1120 oder so kaufen.
Du musst eine Umfrage hinzufügen. Klar, ich mache auch noch eine Umfrage, easy.
Was ist besser, Battlefield?
Ich mache die Umfrage, ist man mit 36 ein Boomer? Ja, nein.
Nur Max nicht.
Ja, ich denke, ich denke mir irgendwas aus, dann Kleiner.
Oh Mann, Sachen gibt es.
Aber das ergibt Sinn, wenn ich ich kriege so viel Schwachsinn YouTube Posts bei mir auf dem Handy gezeigt.
Der macht auch Voting, der macht auch Voting.
Der macht richtig gute Videos, der Typ.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt, den Stress mit Amazon und Elasticsearch?
Elasticsearch hat jetzt ihre Lizenz geändert, weil Amazon Elasticsearch anbietet und so tut, als wenn sie gepartnet mit Elasticsearch, obwohl sie gar nicht gepartnet sind mit Elasticsearch.
Und jetzt hat Elasticsearch die Lizenz geändert, dass Amazon das irgendwie nicht mehr machen kann.
Oder so in die Richtung, Alter. Total wir.
Amazon sagt hart, das Einzige, wisst ihr, was das Einzige ist, wo Amazon wirklich überhaupt gar nicht sagt?
Wenn du da einfach nur Kunde bist und Sachen kaufst, da ist Amazon der beste Shop.
Bei anderen Sachen kann man sich darüber streiten.
By the way, denkt dran, Jett, ihr benutzt hier auch gerade Amazon.
Was verdienst du bei der Arbeit? Ich hatte letztens Fachinformatiker.
Also die Frage kommt ja öfters. Alter.
What the fuck.
Nicht abkratzen.
Also die Frage kommt ja öfters.
Und ich kann die jedes Mal nicht richtig beantworten, weil ich das selber nicht weiß.
Ich habe wirklich legit keine Ahnung, was ich genau verdiene.
Ich habe aber schon ein paar Mal den Tarifvertrag gezeigt und da kannst du dir das Mindeste zusammenreiben.
Ich finde es jetzt aber nicht.
Das ist nicht so.
Die Chrome History sagt.
Das ist das ist der Tarifvertrag für Versicherung.
Da guckst du rein.
Ich habe 14 Jahre und bin glaube ich Stufe 6 oder 7 oder so.
Und dann, ich glaube Stufe 6.
Ich kann es mir nicht merken.
Und dann kommst du irgendwie mit dem Tarifvertrag ein bisschen über 60k aufs Jahr gerechnet.
So, da musst du bei mir nochmal abziehen, dass ich nur vier Tage arbeite.
Und dann musst du noch ein bisschen was draufhauen, was ich jetzt nicht sage, weil ich auch nicht weiß, ob ich das sagen darf.
Und ich auch nicht aus dem Kopf weiß.
Das ist ja das Mindeste, da kann auch noch Bonus draufkommen.
Aber da hast du schon mal das Mindeste.
Wenn du das aus dem Tarifvertrag nimmst und rechnest auf vier Tage um, dann weißt du ungefähr, was es ist.
So, die untere Grenze.
Banggood, beste.
China ist eine.
Exzellent, ja.
Ich habe auch nicht so viel.
Geht das auf Twitch?
Leute, Leute, wir machen eine Runde Subscriber Raten.
Das muss heute noch gehen.
Warte mal, aber noch nicht anfangen.
Ja, genau, AGV Versicherung.
Richtig.
So sieht es aus.
So Leute.
Also, ihr dürft jetzt posten.
Was meint ihr, wie viele Subs habe ich?
Wer richtig liegt, der gewinnt einen Sub oder kann sich jemand aussuchen, der einen Sub bekommt.
Wer öfters dabei ist, hat natürlich bessere Chancen, weil er einfach so ungefähr mitzählen kann.
So grob.
So, lassen wir mal kurz laufen.
Der Chat ist ganz schön am Spam hier wieder.
So, okay.
Fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins, stopp.
So, hier nach dem Strich gibt es nichts mehr.
Also, ich habe gerade 356, hat keiner gepostet.
355 hat einer gepostet.
355, exellent.
Jetzt müssen wir gucken, ob 357 nicht einer gepostet hat.
Fuck.
Moment, der hat später gepostet.
Hat er später gepostet?
Nee, der ist noch drin.
Okay, also LP mit Wilson kriegt einen und es waren ja zwei Stück.
Nee, 355.
Und blue marshmallow kriegt einen.
Muss ich bei euch mal nur raussuchen hier.
Exquisite.
LP mit Wilson kriegt einen.
Der hat keinen, das passt.
Dem kann man am wenigsten direkt einen giften.
Ich kann nicht giften, weil ich das Fenster nicht sehe und ich das Fenster nicht verschieben kann.
Das ist auch geil.
Exellent.
So, und dann hatten wir blue.
Blue was?
Irgendwas marshmallow.
Ah nee, blue mit 1u marshmallow.
Exellent.
Subscriptions gibt es hier wieder Leute.
Dann kriegt er auch noch einen.
Der hat auch keinen.
Ja, das passt.
Wunderbar.
Exellent.
So, und jetzt habe ich quasi 5 Euro an Twitch überwiesen damit, wenn ich selbst gifte.
Weil die Hälfte kriegt natürlich trotzdem Twitch, ne?
Also auch wenn ich gifte.
Man hätte ja irgendwie so einen Deal machen können, so nach dem Motto.
Keine Ahnung, kostet dann nur ein bisschen Gebühr oder so.
Ach, keine Ahnung, dafür.
Oder du kannst giften und bekommst dafür nichts, hätte man machen können.
Aber ja, ja.
Merkt euch das?
Ja, ihr könnt es euch merken.
Aber wenn ihr das nächste Mal dabei seid, habt ihr ganz gute Chancen.
Jaja.
Nee, aber wie gesagt, das mit Amazon Elastic Search ist gerade ein richtig, richtig großes
Ding.
Weil ich habe mich heute Morgen versucht, um ein Meeting zu drücken.
Das hat nicht geklappt.
Ich habe das richtig.
Kennst du Curl, Kegway Services?
Nein.
Gibt es eine Punkt Services, Ul?
Soll ich das mal ausprobieren?
Curl, Kegway Services?
Warum gibt es sowas?
Warum?
Warum existiert sowas überhaupt?
Ach, du hast das gemacht, nice.
Zeig mal her.
Kegway Services.
Guck mal hier.
Perfekt.
Auch richtig gedockert.
Der DevOps Mode ist wieder aktiviert.
Node, Kegway, GS.
Super lange ist es.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Wie hast du das konvertiert?
Du musstest ja irgendwie das Bild zu...
Ach, hier.
Loading Frames.
Ja.
Kegway Services.
Gut, dass wir...
Jetzt haben wir da was gelernt.
Aber hauptsache verdockert.
Vor... was?
Vor Ass.
Fuck off.
Das kenne ich.
Fuck off as a service kenne ich.
Jetzt wurde es...
Ja, ja.
Das habe ich.
Das...
Aber Parrot Life ist auch nochmal geil.
Parrot.life.
Der ist auch top.
Ja, nee, aber das kenne ich.
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Das beste...
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Das beste Programm auf GitHub ist immer noch GitHub the fuck.
Das hat nichts irgendwie damit zu tun.
Das ist eine App, die korrigiert dich, wenn du dich verschrieben hast.
Guckt, upget install vim und das sagt, oh nee, vertippt, dann sagst du gibst du ein fuck
und dann versucht das zu korrigieren.
Eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Sinnhaftigkeit, weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das Ding hat auch bloß 58k Sterne, was extrem viel ist, weil das the fuck heißt.
Als nächstes brauchen wir noch PepePunk, please, gibt es die Domain, gibt es die Domain,
please?
Gibt es da Ranking, ah, das können wir uns tatsächlich mal angucken.
Gibt es, gibt es, gibt es, please als Domain, ah, das wäre natürlich praktisch.
Es gibt auch mittlerweile jeden Crap als Domain, warum gibt es please nicht als Domain.
So was, nee, auch nicht, okay, gibt es Topstar Ranking, ja, das kenne ich, das kenne ich,
wobei man halt sagen muss, Alter, Microsoft, das hätte man sich zu Ballmer Zeiten von
Microsoft wirklich nicht ausmalen können.
Dass man die Microsoft Organization auf einer Open Source, also erstens, dass die das ja
auch noch kaufen, aber auf einer Open Source-Software-Plattform Nummer 1 ist.
Emoji Domain Registration, exellent, das brauchen wir, das brauchen wir.
Da muss ich mir unbedingt was registrieren.
Domain, Search Domain, aha, okay, dann, dann, dann sortieren, da, da müssen wir uns jetzt
unbedingt Emoji Picker schicken, das ist aber bestimmt schon weg, die lege Henne, not
available, okay.
Es gibt ja ansonsten, es gibt ja kaum gute, gute Emojis, gibt es das, gibt es das Kotz,
das Kotz Emoji, kann man hier suchen drin, äh, Puke, wie, gibt es nicht, warum ist das
nicht im, hier, das ist das, das allerwichtigste Emoji, exquisite, kostet, weiß, ist doch
gar nicht so, so teuer, mein 4,99 im Jahr ist doch in Ordnung, kotzemoji.ws, rein da,
es ist eine lustige, es ist eine lustige Gag Idee, ja, funktioniert dann, kann man dann,
kann man dann wirklich sowas hier in den Browser dann, dann schreiben, also, okay, der, der
macht das, der encode das dann auch, ist okay, das finde ich nice, shit, ob man DNS überhaupt
so Sonderzeichen frisst, na gut, ne, also, das, das, das will er fressen, ne, okay, zeig
mal, was sind denn so die aktuellen Topgitter-Projekte, haben die auch, haben die auch Ranking nach
Monate, weil so insgesamt ist jetzt nicht so spannend, ne, ne, das kann man nicht machen,
ne, nicht nach Monaten, nach Monaten hat er GitHub selbst, China-Kram, View, View, Alter,
hat View mittlerweile viele Sternchen, ja, mehr als React, oder, ja, ähnlich viel, und
Bootstrap, aber guckt euch mal an, das ist ja fast, das besteht ja, das besteht ja zu
90% aus JavaScript bei GitHub hier, das habe ich, das habe ich noch nie verstanden, ich
bin da gar kein allzu großer Fan von, Latter, aber die Hälfte ist ja auch schon hier, die
Hälfte ist ja dann, kommt gleich noch Google dabei, ja, was, GitHub Trends, was gibt's
denn da so, äh, was, Git, GitHub, ah, Pull-Request, okay, das ist auch ganz interessant, welche
Sprachen da vorne mit dabei sind, ah, i, was macht das auf Platz 5, gehst sofort, i,
warum, was soll, warum ist so eine Kack-Sprache, bitte schön vor, jede Menge guten Sprachen,
na gut, weil halt C++, weil es viele in C++ gibt, aber warum, was soll da scheiße, Alter,
okay, das schwarze ist C, ne, das schwarze C++, C++, das da, okay, zeig mal, das geht
auch noch nuff, das, das, ich mein, das war mal auf nem guten Weg 2013, das geht auch
noch hoch, na gut, es geht alles hoch, weil GitHub immer mehr benutzt wird, Cobol gibt's
gar nicht, ist gar nicht da, und ABAP auch nicht, Fortran, oh fuck, Fortran ist dabei,
oh, excellent, excellent, hm, es gibt ernsthaft Fortran-Code auf GitHub, das muss ich mir
jetzt angucken, gibt's das, tatsächlich, Wahnsinn, und Cobol, nur, nur die wichtigen
Sachen, Cobol-Programmierkurs, das ist, okay, das ist mal wieder bezeichnet für die Cobol,
das ist mal wieder bezeichnet für Cobol, das Top-Repo ist nicht etwas in dieser Sprache
programmiertes oder Libraries für die Sprache, nein, es ist ein Buch, wie man den Kack überhaupt
verwendet.
Okay, JavaScript wundert mich nicht, dass es oben ist, Pies ist auch voll im Trend,
Java, Java wisst ihr wo, jetzt wisst, Chat, was meint ihr woran es liegt mit Java, also,
was meint ihr woran das meiner Meinung nach liegt an Java, dass das so abgeht, China,
richtig, ja, Android sicherlich auch, wobei ja so viele Open-Source-Android-Apps da sind,
ich würde hauptsächlich sagen China, ohne Scheiß, die Chinesen, die stehen unglaublich
auf Java, ich weiß nicht was mit denen los ist, aber gut, die haben ja bei anderen Sachen
auch unmenschliche Bedingungen, warum dann nicht auch Java, da weiß man schon Bescheid.
Wo ist mein Java, wo ist mein Java, ja, hier, da, was ist das Problem mit C++, dieses Fast
willst du jetzt nicht aufmachen, dann hör ich nämlich nicht mehr auf, ich muss jetzt
auf, was haben wir denn da, aber sie schabschlägt sich auch ganz gut, muss man sagen, Swift,
Swift wird unbeliebter, guckt euch das mal an, Swift, wie sieht es mit Objective-C aus,
wo ist das, ah, ok, wenigstens, wenigstens Apples, ja, Lua, Wishful Basic, ja, gibt's
halt, Verilog, Matlab, PHP, ja, das wundert mich nicht, PHP ist immer noch sau beliebt,
Perl, na, Gott sei Dank, Jason, das ist eigentlich, ok, Go, ja, Go ist sehr beliebt, ja, ganz
viele Cloud-Projekte, die da angesagt sind, sind, ja, Ruby, ganz viele Cloud-Projekte
und Dinge, die damit zu tun haben, sind in Go-Programm, Ruby ist nicht mehr so weit vorne
und es hatte, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, Ruby ist eine super Programmiersprache, ja, also
neben C-Sharp ist Ruby meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache, aber wisst ihr woran das liegt, klar kenne
ich die Talks, wisst ihr woran das liegt, dass das hier so beliebt war und ab hier abgekackt
ist, es hatte nur einen Grund, dass das überhaupt mal so weit oben war, bei 20%, guckt mal,
am Anfang 20% müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, 20%, das lag nur an Rails, das lag nur an
Rails am Anfang und danach hier, also Rails war angesagt und dann irgendwann kam Node.js
und dieses ganze JavaScript-Ökosystem für Web-Anwendungen, was den ganzen Leuten besser
gefallen hat und damit hat Ruby halt extrem an Relevanz verloren.
Was ist das hier, guckt euch das mal an, Python war schon immer gut, Emacs, Lisb, alter, wer
mehr Klammern hat, hat gewonnen, Wimscript, ok, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich schlimmer
finde, Wimscript oder Lisb, was ist Coq, Leute, warum gibt es eine Programmiersprache,
was Coq heißt, Verilog kenne ich nicht, Coqwoo, bricht bestimmt Coq aus, Puppet, Puppet ist
drin aber Ansible und so nicht, ok, Puppet ist auch älter, was ist Roff, hab ich alles
noch nie gehört, ey und ich gehe mal davon aus, hier sind auch nur die beliebtesten reingeflossen,
ja, guckt mal Leute, ändert sich einfach kaum das ganze Jahr über was, interessante
Zeug, ja, das finde ich cool, da geht Hut, geht Hut, alles klar, geht Hut, bestimmt auch
eine View Anwendung, ne, React, Coq ist in Beweise A, das ist für Big Prane, Quick Muffs,
Leute, stimmt, stimmt, Ansible ist, ja, ist recht, Ansible ist Jammel, steht da Jammel
drin, ne, tja, Leute, ich gehe jetzt off und ich mach noch einen Community Post auf YouTube,
guck mal, wie big ist Shell nicht, hatten wir gerade nicht so viel, Power Shell glücklicherweise
verschwindet gering, tja Leute, ich muss echt sagen, wenn ich einen Tag net gestreamt
hab, fehlt mir was, deswegen bin ich heute nochmal angekommen, der Frazier, wo ist er,
ist er on, nope, okay, ich bin weg Leute, machs gut, Kanal Punkt, ja, mal gucken, ich
bin weg, wir sehen uns morgen, bis dann, see you.